first of all you look fantastic thank
you good this is different what happened
to the DES what happened yeah it looked
like you were coming here for a bank
loan you know I did I had a desk in a
microphone for 26 years then I thought
let's let people see my upper thigh
guess what guess what the reaction has
not been positive actually what happened
the desk got repossessed are we you got
a cake cutting your payment's up it's
funny that we could see your legs for
yeah it's kind of interested well
interesting or very sexy they're very
long
my body proportions are insane I have a
very small torso and then in crazy legs
do that again what are your legs look
longer than the other one
I'm not okay all right I'm doing that on
purpose
there is a second word I heard like
three people gasp one noticeable when
he's walk yeah well except by only going
circles yeah let's talk about you and
then we'll get back to why I'm misshapen
you're a you're a single man you're
successful I'm just I'm just guessing
that dating opportunities must be must
be quite good for you is that is that a
fair thing to say it's cool you know I
try to pace myself you know I mean like
I'm doing like Bumble and Bumble you
have to talk me through these things
because I'd been awful
I've been I've been married for 19 years
and off the dating scene four five so
please it works do you
so bumble what you did bumble and which
one is bumble bumble is the one with the
women actually select you so you can
like you could swipe all you want if
they don't pick you they got to send a
message first two also so right okay its
own its own women okay so you you liked
doing that you'd you have success with
that was really cool about it like this
funny cuz nobody believed on me so I
gotta be arguing with women no no like
why would you be on here okay yeah I get
these weird dams like all my other
social media is you right
oh they thought you were so imposing is
they yes they only got like faking it
like cuz you know tell me Hannibal told
me about Hannibal Burres is a plan that
told me about bumble Bryan was in Canada
and this is true so I can tell you at
ISM but he would just he was just coming
up on bomb he's like yeah let's go we
gotta go to this Popeyes Chicken
right so you would go with him to a
Popeyes trip to a Popeye's Chicken to
meet someone that he wanted to meet on
bumble yeah okay
how did that work out what a chicken was
good
okay I'm bringing a friend so I'm
curious about this and you do you date
there's a lot of men in your position
that might date much younger women and
others that might stay in their age
range what are you doing I like my age
range if I can I mean most the time
think I am meeting like 25 and up cuz
I'll be 40 this year but I like I love
older women too like I somebody you just
know what it is you know you could just
well you could just sit down with
somebody and yeah I don't have to talk
and you because Justin understands just
me chilling yeah like we don't have to
do it well gonna be talking about we
don't have to talk about Dave for you
know I hate that to that and it is like
the older women like when you're gonna
bake a shoe with her like they don't
they don't care about the activity you
know you go to somebody to yardies
activities you've got all that energy
this is way too much energy fam like I
said I want to be there I want to be
that couple like they're like that could
change the Amanar you get fully dressed
but you know you still want to do this
yeah yeah I didn't want to do an
activity when I was 25 I certainly don't
want to do one now so yeah I know and
also you have the same frame of
reference right like I understand what
you're talking about the music you like
that's another thing too is weird now
cuz a lot of the nineties music is old
school now which is crazy to me yeah but
I listed some Jodie's those cool
well when were they born coming you're
going out with but you gotta stand some
the nineties kids are adults now yeah
that's crazy
the nineties kids the first three bulls
championships kids love that everyone's
got their own frame of reference mine is
our show this started in 93 and I meet
people that work for us who are full-on
adults and they work for us and they
weren't born when the show started as
crazy they weren't born they and and so
when they look at stuff from our first
season it's like me looking at people
landing on the moon you know let me fake
that you know that's me
[Applause]